bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine sur tv fil 78 le 7-8 lecture le
journal de la rédaction voici les titres
de ce lundi 16 juin la philo pour
débuter la session 2014 du baccalauréat
les oeuvres d'art et duck tales notre
perception doit-on tout faire pour être
heureux et quelques-uns des sujets au
programme pour les lycéens mais en plus
du stress de l'épreuve certains devait
aussi composer avec la peur d'être en
retard en raison de la grève des
transports alors que la réforme des
rythmes scolaires divise enseignants
parents d'élèves et politiques la fcpe
vient de tenir son congrès départemental
annuel l'avenir de l'école au coeur des
discussions le bilan de la journée
mondiale du don du sang alors qu'il
manque toujours des donneurs dans
certaines régions elle nous ferons le
point sur l'île de france et les
yvelines avec le docteur denis pagès est
de l'établissement français du sang
l'image du jour pour débuter ce journal
cet après midi pendant près de trois
heures igor bogdanoff soutenu par son
frère a été entendu à la barre du
tribunal correctionnel de versailles il
reproché à l'animateur des missions
scientifiques passionnés d'hélicoptères
à d'avoir falsifié son carnet de vol et
de ne pas avoir présenté lors d'une
demande de dérogation pour se poser sur
le parking d'un centre commercial à
étampes le tribunal correctionnel rendra
son délibéré le 30 juin prochain le
président du tribunal a abandonné les
poursuites concernant la licence
d'aéronautique falsifiés licence qu'ils
possèdent bien en ce qui concerne l'
usage de faux sur le carnet de vol son
avocat a demandé la relaxe argumentant
que pour atterrir sur un parking ne
m'avait pas besoin de présenter ce
carnet et que les heures falsifiés était
bien justifiée par des vols à but
humanitaire l'animateur qui aujourd'hui
elle n'hésite pas à évoquer un
acharnement policier on les écoute au
micro d'olivier maniscalco et de patrick
jacques de dixmude moi je pense que le
policier ça a été dit tout à l'heure à
l'audience par un avocat
tout simplement décidé de faire un
carton sur une personnalité entre
guillemets quelqu'un de connu et vous
savez très bien que lorsque
on arrive à mettre en cause une
personnalité connue et on récupère une
partie de l'énergie si on peut dire
qu'on a injecté dans le dans le même
dispositif alors je pense que c'est ça
cette mort suspecte à présent d'un
cycliste à maurepas une enquête vient
d'être ouverte après la découverte d'un
corps sur la chaussée dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche sans papiers sans
casque mais à proximité d'un vélo qui
pourrait lui appartenir le décès de cet
homme surprend la police judiciaire de
versailles une autopsie va être
pratiquée le bac 2014 coup d'envoi ce
lundi matin avec la traditionnelle
épreuve de philosophie dans le
département des yvelines ils sont près
de 10000 à passer l'examen nous étions
au lycée hoche à versailles premier
soulagement pour les équipes encadrantes
la grève des transports on n'a pas eu
d'incidence mathilde qu'à berne et
sébastien combes
lycée hoche pas de panique dans cet
établissement versaillais à 8 heures
aucun candidat ne manquait à l'appel les
proviseurs avaient reçu des consignes
strictes du ministère de l'éducation
nationale
sur l'accueil effectivement des élèves
qui arrivera éventuellement en retard
les accueillir pendant une heure après
la distribution des sujets et de leur
accorder un temps équivalent à leur
retard
dans la mesure où le retard était
justifiée effectivement par les
problèmes de la sncf ici près de 400
élèves se sont penchés sur l'épreuve de
philosophie une épreuve plus ou moins
redoutée banon j'étais pas trop stressé
parce que j'avais bien réviser pendant
la semaine de révisions j'étais assez
confiant de moi on est plus stressé pour
les matières scientifiques du conte et
en hesse conques la philo non j'ai
plutôt l'habitude de pas forcément
beaucoup réussir en philosophie donc je
me disais qu pierre
j'avais une mauvaise note et j'avais
l'habitude très stressée mais j'ai pris
un médicament et après ça lui mais pas
spécialement parce que je pense que
c'est aussi un travail qui se fait sur
toute l'année suffit-il d'avoir le choix
pour être libre ou pourquoi chercher à
se connaître deux sujets de dissertation
pour l'épreuve de philosophie des
terminales en économie et social pas de
quoi effrayer colline elle choisit
l'étude de texte lui de hannah arendt
une fois dans ma copie déjà choisi
plutôt vite les deux dissertations
n'espérez pas tellement donc j'ai choisi
le tout l'étude de textes et je pensais
que j'aurais du mal à rentrer dedans et
au final j'ai lu deux ou trois fois et
après ça allait beaucoup mieux j'ai
passé une heure et demie sur mon
brouillon et après je suis sorti en
avant c'est pas forcément ce qu'il faut
faire mais je suis plutôt contente de
main je fais partie des meilleurs
établissements de l'île de france
filière s et es sont présentés l'année
dernière le lycée afficher plus de 99 %
de réussite alors l'année dernière les
résultats autorités ont été excellents
99 en tout 99 et quand on a dix neuf et
demi pour cent la particularité de auch
c'est qu'effectivement on a dans
l'accueil de très très bons élèves à
l'entrée en seconde et on garde de la
totalité de nos élèves en seconde
première terminale
collines et ses camarades doivent encore
se concentrer sur la suite des épreuves
au programme mardi histoire et
géographie en tout plus de 17000
candidats se présentent au baccalauréat
dans le département et cette lycéenne
colline que nous retrouverons jeudi
après sa plus grosse épreuve l'économie
coefficient 9 prochain reportage donc à
suivre dans une autre édition et si dans
cet établissement la grève à la sncf n'a
pas eu d'incidence sur les retards des
élèves les cheminots étaient bel et bien
mobilisés et reste en colère contre la
réforme ferroviaire qui sera étudiée à
partir de demain à l'assemblée
c'était même une trentaine vous le voyez
à le faire savoir devant la permanence
du député socialiste des yvelines jean
philippe mallet permanence basée à
trappes ils demandent le report de cette
réforme alors que le gouvernement
n'entend pas céder il annonce le
maintien du mouvement de blocage jusqu'à
mercredi le député socialiste sera quant
à lui est l'invité mardi du 7-8
politique il aura l'occasion de réagir
en direct sur ce plateau à partir de
18h30 première diffusion 19h30 et le
replay ensuite à suivre sur notre site
internet
conséquence première des nouveaux
rythmes scolaires l'embauchent des
centaines d'animateurs a à travers la
france pour prendre en charge les
enfants pour leur proposer des activités
également le recrutement qui est en
cours dans plusieurs villes notamment à
montigny le bretonneux qui pour répondre
aux besoins vient de proposer un forum
dédié nous en avons profité pour savoir
quel était le profil des candidats alors
que certains parents s'inquiètent de
leur compétence catherine zonato et
david charpentier
aurélie à 22 ans avec un bac sociale la
jeune femme a démarré des études
d'infirmière avant de se rendre compte
que cette voie ne lui convenait pas elle
veut changer d'orientation j'adore les
enfants
l'animation c'est quelque chose que
j'adore que j'ai découvert grâce à mon
bafa en fait j'ai fait le bafa comme ça
et ça a été un peu coup de coeur le
changement d'orientation professionnelle
c'est aussi ce qui a conduit c'est lui
en courtoise ancienne éducatrice
spécialisée à postuler être avec les
enfants les suivre dans leur rythme dans
leur progression tant au niveau éducatif
que
créatif autre profil aurélia ses talents
courtoise mène des études de théâtre ce
qu'elle aime dans le type de postes
proposés ici c'est de pouvoir travailler
dans la durée en tant que vacataire on
n'a pas beaucoup d'opportunités de faire
des activités suivies avec tes des
enfants avec des écoles avec n'est plus
là comme bouche trou on va dire et là je
trouvais que c'était l'occasion
peut-être de monter un projet avec tes
enfants sur une année j'adore travailler
avec les enfants si son sens de la joie
de vivre est la bonne humeur et sa crête
de passer avec eux enfin dernier profil
celui qui fait déjà partie de l'équipe
d'animateurs et souhaite consolider son
poste j'ai fait un peu d'animation en
tant que vacataire pour la mairie de
montigny déjà et vu que ça m'a plu que
j'aimerais bien me lancer dans la vie
active et et commencer à à faire ma vie
on va dire donc j'ai décidé de venir à
mairie pour postuler quatre candidats
différents parmi la trentaine qui sont
venus prétendre à un poste en mairie de
montigny le bretonneux un premier forum
pour présenter 28 offres à temps complet
ou à temps partiel
un vrai emploi d'animateur répartis sur
toute l'année il ya effectivement une
palette assez large soit des gens qui
sont en cours en reconversion soit
effectivement des jeunes qui sont qui
choisissent une voix animations parce
qu'effectivement c'est un métier qui
leur permet qui qui va je pense
effectivement continuer à évoluer ce
métier d'animation avec la réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui va permettre de
valoriser et leurs
leur avenir pas simple de recruter car
les demandes des villes sont nombreuses
réforme des rythmes scolaires obligent
le service scolaire va opérer une
première sélection les candidats retenus
seront reçus pour un deuxième entretien
et si certains ne présente pas le sésame
indispensable c'est à dire le bafa la
commune envisage des formations à la
rentrée rien n'est laissé au hasard le
temps presse la rentrée c'est le 2
septembre
toujours autour des rythmes scolaires
mais elles encourent cette fois ci des
parents et des enseignants qui se
révoltent ils demandent au maire jean
michel fourgous de revoir sa copie
notamment sur la durée de la pause
méridienne rallongé et qui passe à deux
heures trente mais aussi sur les
activités proposées jugées largement
insuffisantes jean michel fourgous ump
et qui s'opposent à cette réforme et a
donc choisi et d'assurer le service
minimum pour cette rentrée une
manifestation des parents d'élèves et
des enseignants est annoncé jeudi à 18h
à proximité de l'hôtel de ville une
réunion entre les élus de cette commune
et les directeurs d'école se déroule
actuellement lundi soir nous en
reparlerons demain éducation toujours la
fcpe vient de tenir son congrès
départemental à magny les hameaux
l'occasion de s'interroger sur l'école
de demain d'autant que la fédération de
parents d'élèves est elle favorable à la
mise en place de ces nouveaux rythmes
catherine plateau jonathan vilma des
voix s'élèvent surtout pour dénoncer la
réforme des rythmes scolaires d'autres y
sont favorables comme la fcpe une des
fédérations de parents d'élèves alors
quelle école pour demain c'est la
question que nous sommes allés poser à
trois spécialistes s'il doit d'abord
être une école bienveillante une école
qui soit à l'écouté des enfants qui soit
à l'écouté de leur rythme tout l'enjeu
de la réforme des rythmes scolaires
puisqu'on parle de réforme des rythmes
scolaires c'est ça c'est d'être à
l'écouté rythme des enfants
la semaine de quatre jours a été une
erreur a été une erreur et qui a nui
à l'enseignement aux enseignements des
enfants très clairement il fallait
changer quelque chose donc la réforme
des rythmes utile oui ça aussi permis la
collaboration avec un certain nombre
d'acteurs sur le terrain parents
d'élèves enseignants animateurs services
municipaux autour de la définition
d'objectifs communs aux services et au
bénéfice des enfants il faut quand même
comprendre que c'est une formidable si
comme on le dit et opportunités pour que
tous les partenaires de l'éducation
travaille ensemble que les associations
que les collectivités territoriales que
l'éducation nationale travaillent
ensemble reste que travailler ensemble
cela va prendre du temps tout le monde
semble s'accorder sur ce point il va
falloir du temps il va falloir peut-être
plusieurs années pour que ça fonctionne
mais j'espère que ça va fonctionner
parce que de toute façon on parlait tout
à l'heure d'échec scolaire c'est une un
des moyens un des moyens importants pour
résoudre cette question là et faire que
tous nos jeunes réussissent dans le
système scolaire c'est une réforme qui
va évoluer au fil du temps qui va
s'adapter et moi je crois qu'on peut
être optimiste
moi je pense en tout cas personnellement
et la fcpe aussi c'était un petit peu
difficile de confier une partie de la
réforme des rythmes éducatif aux
collectivités territoriales qui sont pas
forcément des professionnels de la
ducation contre des villes qui on a les
moyens et qui vont vers développer une
véritable politique éducative en
réussissant à l'ensemble de leur temps
la cohérence de l'ensemble leur temps
des villes riches qui vont mettre en
place des services de garderie et la
même chose chez les villes pauvres la
vraie différence elle est sur
l'engagement des villes il ya tout le
travail sur la pédagogie on va parler
pour les villes autour de la pédagogie
des centres de loisirs qui est un
travail de long terme qui est la
formation des animateurs les animateurs
ont un gros problème de formation
initiale c'est un enjeu vraiment
important qu'il faut auxquels il faut se
consacrer pour que les temps
périscolaires soient de véritables temps
éducatif qualitatif au service des
enfants c'est sur plusieurs années qu'il
faudra vraiment travailler à la réforme
des rythmes éducatif un des objectifs de
la réforme que la france quitte la 25e
place du classement international pisa
mais nos trois spécialistes s'accordent
à dire que cela ne pourra se faire
qu'avec les enseignants et surtout pas
contre rendez-vous le 2 septembre jour
de la rentrée scolaire
14 juin journée mondiale des donneurs de
sang le fs l'établissement français du
sang organisée à cette occasion des
collectes à travers l'hexagone et
notamment dans les yvelines on en parle
ce soir avec le docteur denis pagès
bienvenus merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation quel bilan vous faites de
cette campagne du 14 juin pour votre
bassin celui de l'ouest de
l'ile-de-france heures déjà pour
l'ensemble de l'île de france c'est
positif
puisque nous avons prélevé plus de
donneurs que prévu nous avions prévu
d'en prélever 1330 on a fait 1330 7
compte tenu de ce que ça représente faut
savoir que pour une base comme
versailles par exemple 1337 en moyenne
ce qu'on réalise sur une semaine de six
jours donc c'est un excellent résultat
et pour ce qui concerne la base dont
j'ai la responsabilité qu'ils avaient à
ce qu'on appelle un événementiel pour
cette fois c'était pas à versailles 17 à
boulogne billancourt qui dépend de notre
secteur nous avons fait un peu moins
bien on fait de 136 prélèvements le jour
même
alors nous en prévoyons de 150 mais
globalement le résultat est intéressant
et les plus intéressants par le bruit
qu'on fait pour
solliciter les gens pour attirer leur
attention sur la nécessité
de donner son sang ç'a permis de toucher
de nouveaux donneurs cette opération
parce que c'est le premier but alors
c'est la première ça qui viennent
d'abidjan ces matières d'abord c'est ça
c'est le message qu'on passe aux
donneurs habituels
c'est à dire ne venait pas le 14 nous
notre objectif c'est d'avoir des
nouveaux donneurs et en même temps les
résultats obtenus sont quand même plus
que satisfaisant puisque un donneur qui
vient régulièrement l'entretien médical
dure pas très longtemps et dure 3 4
minutes à nouveau demeure ça dure 8
minutes donc c'est en fait pour
accueillir un nouveau donneur ça nous
prend deux fois plus de temps mais en
même temps c'est une certitude ou en
tout cas une sécurité pour l'avenir et
des profils spécifiques que vous
recherchez est ce que vous allez réussir
à les toucher à travers cette opération
cette année je pense aux hommes plus
qu'aux femmes qui sont recherchés alors
certaines communautés aussi alors il ya
effectivement maintenant on met l'accent
sur la nécessité où le besoin d'avoir
plutôt des donneurs hommes ou des femmes
qui n'ont pas eu d'enfant car ces
dernières au cours de la grossesse
peuvent développer des anticorps qui ne
sont pas bien vécue par les patients qui
ressemble leur sang ce qui n'est pas le
cas bien changer les hommes et puis le
deuxième objectif au niveau national et
de moins faire du quantitatif que du
qualitatif ainsi on a besoin de plus en
plus d'avoir des gens d'origine afro
antillaise qui ont des particularités
biologiques ars et des phénotypes très
spécifique très particulier et qui fait
que si on n'approche pas ou plus près
leur groupe sanguin très spécifiques et
bien il ya des gens qui vont devenir
très rapidement intransférable parce
qu'à chaque fois il y aura une réaction
démolissent dire que les globules rouges
du donneur sont attaqués par les
anticorps du receveur et ça devient des
cas de transfusion impossible et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on essaie d'être le
plus proche possible du groupe sanguin
initial avec ses spécificités qui sont
d'ordre racial mais génétique
aujourd'hui on est bien d'accord il
n'existe aucun produit de substitution
au sang humain avance alors on avait
déjà parlé ensemble si j'ai bon souvenir
du fait que le professeur luc douay
avait réussi à cultiver des cellules des
globules rouges à partir de cellules
souches et que le résultat le plus
probant de sa recherche c'est que c'est
la première fois que ces globules rouges
de culture avait la même durée de vie et
la même efficacité que le bus rouge
produit dans l'organisme récemment les
japonais viennent de cultiver des
plaquettes alors ces plaquettes sont pas
encore tout à fait parfaite et c'est le
mérite d'exister et on pense que dans
d'ici deux trois ans et là ça va
s'étendre au niveau international on va
arriver à produire des plaquettes mais
en laboratoire maintenant il faut être
raisonnable entre passer d'une culture
en laboratoire avec quelques millilitres
même si ces quelques centaines de
militants est passé à l'échelon
industriels je crois que raisonnablement
cédant 20 ans au mieux d'où l'importance
du don du sang et de ses opérations
comme la journée du 14 juin alors le don
du sang en france et non rémunérés seule
une soixantaine de pays procède de cette
façon est ce que c'est le bon système
parce que régulièrement ça revient
faut-il changer la donne rémunérer les
dons du sang ou alors aller vers un
système mixte peut-être alors
petite amie de la médiation de ma part
en fait dans les pays comme l'autriche
si ma mémoire est exact ce qui est
rémunéré en fait disent que
c'est un défraiement c'est le don de
plasma pas le temps de globules rouges
dans états unis ça se fait par exemple
c'est rémunéré toujours pour le plasma
est par contre dans ces cas là c'est un
contrat c'est à dire que vous va vous
demander de venir au moins quatre fois
par an donnez votre sang de plasma et
autres vous avez l'obligation de subir
régulièrement des examens médicaux
spécifiques et que c est vous ne
respectez pas bien vous êtes sorti donc
faut pas croire simplement que c'est
comme ça je pense que c'est les
américains avec leur culture
très spécifique qui pour eux ça
l'ensemble
naturel est sorti dîner nous n'avons pas
tout à fait les mêmes cultures c'est ça
qui bloque en france c'est pas naturel
il faut que le don ça reste gratuit et
bénévole c'est un choix de morale de
société donc ça veut dire que si on dit
bon on accepte de rémunérer ou compenser
on bon il est un mot dans le
dictionnaire pour dire la même chose ça
veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui vont être remises en cause d'anglais
est pas au niveau que du sang donc je
crois que c'est une attitude que
tiennent
les différents gouvernements depuis
longtemps et très personnellement je
pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
que ça ne produit pas j'allais me semble
business dans
dans la relation très particulière qu'on
peut avoir
avec les donneurs et que on leur laisse
en quelque sorte la liberté de venir ou
pas même si on souhaite profondément qui
viennent alors qu'aux états unis s'ils
ne viennent pas ils sont sortis et puis
la crainte aussi sas avait été vécue par
les américains il ya très longtemps en
haïti c'est que le don de sang étaient
rémunérés et qu'ils faisaient pas les
contrôler que les gens et de donner
toutes les huit semaines et des toutes
les quatre semaines donc on avait du
sang qui était à la fois
de qualité médiocre et puis vu le niveau
d'hygiène au niveau d'haïti
bon il ya des antilles autres tares
danger sanitaire
réel et c'est derrière pour laquelle les
états unis ont arrêté de faire des
collectes en haïti je pense que c'est
raisonnable c'est peut-être une position
de principe c'est
mais d'abord c'est celle de mon
établissement c'est celle de l'état et
non seulement je respecte mais je la
partage faut-il rémunérer le don du sang
ça nous allait demander à quelques saint
quentinois s'il partageait pas
travailler six hommes d'accord
non la personne doit donner si elle veut
mais non non pas le pas rémunéré oui
parce que c'est quelque chose qui nous
appartient personnellement donc on doit
monnayer nom doit par énumérer les
élites ont du sens c'est naturel d'aller
donner son sang pour pour les personnes
qui en ont besoin ça doit être gratuit
c'est
c'est vrai que pour en avoir davantage
peut-être qu'il vaudrait mieux rémunérés
non
parce que c'est un don qui doit venir
naturellement et
un don de solidarité je dirais non parce
que sinon ça va être les abus à tout un
tas de dérive on a notre côté on a
vraiment des besoins de sang
je sais pas comment faire enfin j'me
réponse est très mitigé et de deux par
principe durer non les avis très
partagés dr denis pagès vous avez écouté
avec attention oui alors simplement une
réponse je pense qu'il ya défaut de
clore le débat va un petit peu
l'enterrer à partir du moment où on
accepte de payer le don du sang il ya
aucune raison de ne pas payer le don de
rein le don de coeur dont une fois où
d'autres organes de sang un organe comme
les autres un peu particulier donc à
partir du moment où on commercialise le
sens il n'y a aucune raison pour ne pas
commercialiser des organes et donc
ça devient carrément impossible la
réflexion dépasse le simple cadre du don
du sang aujourd'hui quels sont les
besoins pour le secteur à la veille des
grandes vacances forcément il ya
toujours le moment où vous alerter un
peu la population est ce que c'est
encore pour le moment compte tenu des
excellents résultats de du 14 juin on a
à peu près tranquille jusque aller au 10
12 août on est en état de stocks on
n'est pas trop mal et
chaque année et c'est pas à cause et j
mds ce à cause des vacances d'été là on
commence à être un petit peu en
difficulté et donc moi si j'ai un
conseil une recommandation à donner aux
donneurs c'est commencer à donner à
partir de la deuxième quinzaine de
juillet
la première quinzaine d'août et nous ça
ne régule en notant que les services
hospitaliers qui consomment du sang mais
un certain qu'ils ferment en août parce
qu'ils ont passé le personnel pour nous
maintenir avec un niveau de sécurité
d'efficacité correct donc en fait
venez donner à partir de du 10 juillet
comme si c'étaient les 14 juin mais le
10 juillet une dernière question pour
répondre à cette pénurie parfois de don
du sang est ce qu'il faut ouvrir le don
aux personnes homosexuelles parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est interdit la
polémique revient régulièrement ce
week-end c'est jean luc romero hommes
politiques la socialiste apparenté
socialiste militant associatif il a
tweeté il dénonce la poursuite de cette
restriction demande au gouvernement de
la lever cette interdiction
moi j'attends que madame marisol
touraine répondent puisque la question
lui est adressée je me fais mes
collègues et moi même établissement
français ne fait que ne font que suivre
les recommandations de l'europe et pas
simplement de la france le fait
d'étudiants un dossier ne veut pas dire
forcément de se terminer par une
conclusion positive ceci dit c'est pas
vraiment se poser la question qu'on se
pose la question mais c'est pas dire
aider les homosexuels hommes ne sont pas
montrés du doigt comme je l'avais déjà
dit d'ailleurs précédemment il y a des
raisons
épidémiologique qui font que le risque
de contamination que ce soit les
hépatites ou l'archivé est dix fois plus
important chez les donneurs homosexuels
hommes à celle donnée remo sexuelle
c'est pas les montrer du doigt c'est
simplement le principe de précaution
merci docteur denis pagès responsable du
pôle ouest ile de france 2 merci encore
coupe du monde de football à présent
l'entrée en compétition des français ils
l'ont emporté 3-0 hier une bonne entrée
en matière suivi par plus de 16 millions
de téléspectateurs notamment à bois
d'arcy ou la ville proposait une
retransmission dans sa salle de
spectacle les images de jonathan ville
c'est tous les quatre ans donc
effectivement l'abri blues je pouvais
pas louper ce rendez vous on sait pas
combien il y aura de personnes manquent
tout cas ce dont je suis sûr c'est que
la france va gagner justement un petit
pronostic 3 0 un supporter bien inspiré
avant le coup d'envoi de la rencontre
france honduras dimanche soir s'ils
étaient nombreux à croire en la victoire
de la france ils étaient en revanche un
peu moins à prédire un tel dénouement
ici à bois d'arcy l'abri blues la salle
de spectacle retransmettait le premier
match des bleus et c'est ensemble que
les spectateurs ont vécu l'ouverture du
score
l'équipe de france volontaire
et qui joue un football plaisant nous
avions engagé mais qu'il continue comme
ça c'est parfait très bon état d'esprit
il aurait pu mettre au moins deux buts
je pense facilement et on n'a pas une
chance et j'espère qu'en deuxième
mi-temps volant et font quand même alors
m au moins deux autres buts un voeu
exaucé par karim benzema
3 0 score final sur le fond comme sur la
forme cette équipe de france version
didier deschamps séduit et sembles
réconcilier avec son public on est
content que l'équipe de france ait gagné
et bien entamé sa coupe du monde c'est
super pas trop mal à 3 contre une équipe
que tu es vachement dur à jouer ont
quand même le public devrait donc venir
encore en masse lors des deux prochaines
retransmissions programmés ici à l'abri
blues de bois d'arcy c'est un grand
événement pour nous parce que c'est le
début de la coupe du monde c'est la
france la france qui est en pleine
dynamique j'ai l'impression énorme on
avait envie nous de transmettre ce
dynamisme à la population en sixième
dans un endroit qui est plutôt
très identitaire pour bois d'arcy c'est
très connu c'est la bri bluesé l'ont
fait les concerts c'est là où la
jeunesse se retrouvent c'était vraiment
où trouver justement pour qu on
retransmet les matchs de l'équipe de
france ici
fin du journal pour ce 16 juin demain
mardi je vous retrouve toujours en
direct à partir de 18h pour revoir tous
nos reportages les précédentes éditions
et nos émissions rendez vous sur le site
internet de la chaîne très bonne soirée